Brighton's best-kept secret mama sherry
soul food shack is so well-kept it's
losing a thousand pounds a week no on it
twenty past Oh in the morning no day
three I've uncovered a couple of reasons
why I know it's chilled but [ __ ] give
him a lot of children's our step why is
nobody here this time the morning it's
ridiculous firstly the food's good but
it could be so much better
where's where's Bryan a movie hundred
right yeah
secondly there are far too many staff
and most of them are pulling their
weight
later Somali yes at Ralph's allow me
would you do to what he's late nothing
nothing
wash up right now see you washing up as
well she's in she opens up things all
the supplies upstairs you should be
ashamed of yourself
right sherita's next task is to make a
huge batch of macaroni cheese that will
last up for two whole weeks I'll this is
coming up nicely hot from the stove her
food is irresistible people will travel
miles to taste it I like that yeah yeah
Bayless but like a lot of our home
cooking this light is destined for the
freezer
where it's delicious texture and flavor
will be lost forever
we cool beautiful yeah and I don't
understand why you want to freeze it
wait so tell you like well I think I
don't think I want it's not a case of
one I think you got into a habit I've
gotten a habit which is a lazy habit
you're not late now to work so bloody
hard these days is it's a matter
it's definitely lazy if you turned up
for work half an hour late in my kitchen
trust me you'd be home for the day
looking for a new [ __ ] job to be
honest there's no wonder Bryan's lost
half the man's been working the kitchen
for as long as I have but to save money
he's been sidelined so much so he's
rarely involved in actually making any
of the food
there is a kind of a method to my
madness poor youth write it together um
it looks like I'm throwing it together
but I throw it together the exact same
way every six a week so when you're not
doing it who does it I'm doing it that's
one point okay